in the first scene a woman named Chase
wakes up on an unknown island with a
shell in her hand she doesn't remember
anything including her identity and is
puzzled how she ended up there shortly
after we get to know that there are nine
other people stranded on the island with
her all of them are dressed in similar
clothes and have no recollection of who
they are Chase first meets a woman named
Casey who reveals that she woke up with
a knife confused with whatever is
happening Casey threatens to fight but
Chase calms her down and takes the knife
away from her next everyone on the
island gathers in one place and tries to
recall who they are eventually they find
their names on the neck labels of their
shirts the group then tries to figure
out how they ended up on the island one
of them rules out a plane crash or a
ship incident as all of them are in
perfectly good condition everyone having
Amnesia at the same time is also
impossible maybe they all boarded the
same Disney Cruise you can't trust
Mickey in 2022 after failing to find an
answer Chase goes around the island in
search of Clues she is joined by The
Macho of the group Brody and a talkative
guy Donovan the trio ends up finding
different survival items including a
first aid kit buried under the spot
where everyone was lying Chase and Brody
then decide to search for food and fresh
water while Donovan returns to the
others to light a fire after walking for
hours through the jungle Brody and Chase
come across a freshwater Source a
beautiful waterfall in the Heat of the
Moment they also make out seconds later
Chase decides that the romance is enough
for one day but Brody craves more and
tries to assert himself on her enraged
Chase pulls out her knife and threatens
to stab him before running away
elsewhere Donovan and the others go for
a swim in the sea where they are soon
surrounded by sharks everyone panics and
rushes to the shore but poor Donovan is
bitten and taken away after a while
Chase and Brody separately arrive at the
camp she accuses him of having bad
intentions but Brody denies the
allegation before things could escalate
two sensible guys Cooper and Moses
separate them like the Red Sea they then
reveal that a shark killed one of their
friends at night everyone takes a nap
and Chase has a nightmare where she
pulls a gun on an elderly woman soon she
wakes up in a cold sweat and decides to
go for a walk I gotta stop dreaming
about beating up old people a few meters
ahead she surprisingly comes across a
badly wounded but alive Donovan she
immediately alerts everyone and they
carry him back to the camp there is a
trained nurse in the group named Blair
and she starts taking care of Donovan
later Brody suggests moving Inland to
find a better shelter but chasing the
others feel that they should try and
find a way out of the island as everyone
is discussing the youngest members of
the group Mason and Hayden reveal that
they noticed a pattern earlier it turns
out that each of them were located
exactly 39 steps away from one another
when they first woke up on the island on
multiplying 39 with the number of people
present on the island i.e-10 they walked
390 steps and found a signboard that
says find your way back however the
others think that it's a nothing Burger
more insane than Hurley's lottery
numbers they say and return back to the
camp this frustrates Chase and she
smashes her shell in Anger surprisingly
there is a digital key hidden inside it
which she doesn't notice the next
morning Chase wakes up earlier than
everyone and shockingly notices a tent
boat in the sea she immediately swims
towards it barely escaping the sharks
inside she finds multiple suitcases and
a backpack with some bullets and a bunch
of other items which reference the
number 39 an elated Chase then paddles
the tent back to Shore and hides it she
also hides the suitcases separately and
it's revealed that one of them contains
medicine while the other has a locked
box after a while she joins the others
at the camp and watches Casey leave with
Brody in search of food once Deep In the
Jungle the two flirt and start making
out later they returned to the camp and
notice a massive storm approaching from
the distance Brody again insists on
moving Inland and this leads to a
physical altercation between him and
Cooper at last when the group refuses to
follow his orders Brody leaves for the
forest alone in no time the storm
arrives and Chase is forced to to tell
everyone about the tent where they
eventually spend the night the next
morning after the skies clear Chase
Ventures out and finally notices the
digital key she rushes to open the
suitcase and finds a revolver inside
later the young girl Hayden notices a
contrasting change in Casey's demeanor
after she went into the forest with
Brody she presses her for information
and Casey finally reveals that Brody
mistreated her meanwhile Chase and
Cooper hike up a mountain to get a
better look at the island to their
surprise they come across a huge
abandoned hotel with a functional fresh
water fountain afterwards they returned
to the camp and she takes a shot at
Brody again which leads to another
altercation fed up with all the torture
Brody decides to stay on his own that
night Chase again dreams of pulling a
gun on the same the same old woman from
earlier the next morning everyone wakes
up to Brody's dead body he was killed by
the same knife Chase had been carrying
around so expectedly they blame her for
the murder despite her best efforts to
claim that she is innocent when nothing
works Chase starts fighting back it's
clear that she is a trained fighter but
Cooper and the others eventually
outnumber her and knock her unconscious
in the next scene Chase wakes up to find
herself in a room with a nurse this
naturally puzzles her and she demands
answers but the nurse sedates her
instead next Chase wakes up in another
room with a doctor beside her he reveals
that she is actually a prisoner and that
they are in a futuristic Texas
correctional facility Chase is then
escorted to the prison Warden Mr wells's
office confused and angry she demands to
know why she is in prison and why she
was on an island before Wells doesn't
mention the reason for her incarceration
but reveals that the island is actually
a computer simulation called Island whoa
that's clever the nine other people
there are also imprisoned criminals
Wells further explains that the island
is designed to test the criminals and
change them for the better through the
use of harsh techniques anyone who dies
in The simulation dies in real life how
does that help anyone this confuses
Chase even more and she assumes that
everything is a lie but Wells tells her
that she can find out for herself when
she is sent back to the simulation
shortly later she is presented before
the members of The Rehabilitation
Advisory Board they again brief her that
the program's aim is to give prisoners a
second chance at life and see if they
repeat their past behavioral patterns
unless they get bitten by a simulated
shark and die one of the advisory
members feels that chase has failed and
she shouldn't be sent back to Island
because of her self-serving and violent
nature at the halftime break Wells
confides and Chase that although he is
in charge of conducting this
rehabilitation program he doesn't
approve of it he feels that it's a total
waste of money trying to rehabilitate
people who frankly don't deserve it for
instance Brody is incarcerated for
forcing himself onto others but even
inside the rehabilitation program
couldn't change him Wells further
reveals that the program is designed to
kill anyone who kills others he also
confirms that chase did in fact not kill
Brody and it was someone else before
departing chasing choirs about a
recurring dream where she pulling a gun
on an older woman who else simply
replies that it's a memory from her real
life later The Advisory members take a
secret vote and decide to send Chase
back into the program before the
preparations for it begin one of the
advisory members Dr whis privately meets
Chase and warns her that the warden is
secretly manipulating the results of the
simulation she can't prove how but she
is sure of it on her way to the doctor's
room Chase manages to escape and reaches
the simulation room disguised as a
worker there she Witnesses the chamber
where Cooper and the other prisoners
have been kept in cryosleep however
before Chase can investigate more she is
caught and Warden Wells again sends her
back into Island next Chase wakes up
inside the simulation tied up by her
fellow Islanders who believe that she
murdered Brody she insists that she's
innocent and also tries to explain that
they are actually inside a computer
simulation Chase further reveals that
they are all incarcerated criminals who
have been sent off to this island to
prove that they can change No One
Believes her but Cooper admits having a
vague memory talking to a warden who
wears a cowboy hat suddenly the young
girl Hayden has a flashback and
remembers the time that got her
incarcerated it turns out she brutally
killed her husband who she suspected of
cheating on her meanwhile chase
continues to insist that she's innocent
and even accuses one of them of killing
Brody this infuriates the others and
they call her a Serial liar accusing her
of hiding things ever since they got to
this island as the group continues
bickering suddenly two new Islanders
show up they introduce themselves as
Bonnie and Clyde and claim that they
woke up on the other side of the island
in an abandoned Village however when
Chase finds their accents strikingly
similar to the wardens she suspects that
they have been sent to manipulate the
group as Cooper grills the new Islanders
the outspoken brat of the group Taylor
remembers that Bonnie and Clyde are
actually the names of a famous bank
robber cupper whoops bank robber couple
from the 1930s then chase points out
that oddly these two haven't said
anything about the dead body of Brody
which any normal person would be
horrified after seeing with this Bonnie
and Clyde realize that they have blown
their cover that was quick and finally
admit that they are police Marshals much
to everyone's shock the very next second
Clyde approaches Hayden stabs her with a
knife and reveals that it was her who
killed Brody it turns out that Hayden
committed the murder as she was scared
of becoming Brody's next victim
meanwhile Clyde explains that before the
prisoners entered this program they
signed waivers agreeing to the rules of
the program now if they die inside the
simulation they will die in real life
moreover if they kill someone inside the
simulation they will be killed in return
clad then reveals that they altered
everyone's cerebrum so the prisoners
will slowly regain their memories
including why they got incarcerated he
warns them that once they regain their
memories they might want to kill one
another for the horrible things they
have done in real life Clyde then turns
everyone against Chase saying she is
hiding medical supplies and other items
the plan works and everyone becomes
enraged so Chase is forced to leave
before she departs she hands over the
medicine to the group to prove that he's
not a bad guy however she does not
mention the revolver and takes that with
her after a while the second good guy of
the group Moses demands to know how and
when this is all going to end Clyde
responds that it will end when they
reach the other Island however for that
they will need his approval before
leaving he also makes it clear that if
any of them tries to exit the simulation
prematurely he and Bonnie will hunt them
down by this point I'm failing to see
the point of this simulation at all
after burying the deceased bodies Casey
Cooper and Moses decide to go to the
opposite side of the island in search of
food and shelter while the others decide
to stay back in the camp with Donovan
who is still recovering from the shark
bites Donovan thinks the nurse Blair for
her efforts and it becomes clear that he
has feelings for her meanwhile after
hours of traveling Casey and her group
locate a village where they come across
several empty Huts Casey and Moses lay
down to rest while Cooper decides to go
looking for Chase suddenly Casey starts
to regain her memories and sees herself
in a car driving into the ocean back at
the camp the young guy Mason also starts
remembering his past he sees himself
storming into a supermarket with a rifle
and gunning everyone down in sight this
finally reveals that Mason is a deadly
Mass shooter similarly Blair also sees
her past which reveals that she was a
nurse at an old age hospital it turns
out she was incarcerated for killing
many of her elderly patients by
injecting potassium chloride into their
IV bags in her defense Blair claimed
that she only killed the patients who
requested her to put them out of their
misery elsewhere Chase arrives at the
abandoned hotel from earlier and starts
having flashbacks from her past this
time she learns that the old lady in her
dreams is actually her own mother the
vision's terrified Chase but she manages
to calm herself down and soon finds a
key to room 39 she scans the entire room
and locates an envelope hidden behind a
painting inside she finds a picture of a
farm and a picture of herself with her
mother she also finds a picture of
Cooper and her this shockingly reveals
that the two are a couple from real life
the show then flashes back to Casey's
past she works at a diner and is married
with two children however her husband
often punishes her for no reason one day
she meets a handsome man and falls in
love with him the two start meeting
regularly and their bond deepens so
Casey gathers all her courage and
reveals everything to her husband she
also Demands a divorce but the cunning
husband threatens to take their children
away because of this Casey loses hope
for life and decides to end it all at
first she drowns her children in the sea
and then returns home and commits the
unthinkable in front of her abusive
husband similarly it is revealed that
Moses was a far-right activist who blew
up a gas pipeline to bring awareness to
the several injustices going on in the
world however the plan went horribly
wrong and it ended up killing eight
innocent students who were on an
engineering tour in the present Moses
notices a distraught KC and Comforts her
saying they have to forget the past and
move on with their lives Casey obliges
and together they decide to look for
Chase in hopes of getting out of this
simulation on the other hand as Cooper
is wandering around the forest alone he
notices Bonnie and Clyde passing nearby
he eavesdrops on their conversation and
learns that the two are working for an
unidentified person without the
knowledge of The Rehabilitation Advisory
Board this means that someone has
secretly hired Bonnie and Clyde to
sabotage the rehabilitation program by
turning everyone against one another
elsewhere the spoiled brat Taylor has
had enough and decides to leave the
island alone Blair tries to stop her but
Taylor aggressively gets into the tent
boat and sails away after a few hours
she reaches another Island where she
comes across human skulls she also
starts regaining her memories and it
turns out she robbed a bank with her
boyfriend Taylor soon falls asleep and
when she wakes up she finds her right
hand wrapped with a bandage she also
finds some soup that someone apparently
cooked for shortly after Bonnie and
Clyde show up and tell Taylor that she
shouldn't have come to this island as a
cannibal lives here after they leave
Taylor quickly opens her bandage and
freaks out it turns out the cannibal fed
her a soup of her own fingers elsewhere
Donovan also recalls his pass and it's
revealed that he's a dangerously
obsessive man who killed his former
co-worker after she rejected him back in
the simulation he abruptly proposes to
Blair much to her shock she's at a loss
for words and doesn't respond to the
proposal the same day Mason hurts
himself and Blair nurses his wounds this
obviously makes Donovan jealous so he
tries to get her attention by pretending
that a bug got into his eyes and when
they are alone he attempts to turn her
against Mason however this only creeps
Blair out and she leaves abruptly later
when no one is looking the overly
possessed Donovan attacks Mason and
strangles him to death he then hides the
corpse with some leaves meanwhile Blair
recalls the rest of her memory it turns
out she is a lesbian who is married to a
woman elated she rushes to share the
news with Donovan but when she notices
Mason's corpse she pretends to be into
him so as not to anger the deranged man
however at an opportune moment she
covertly gets hold of Mason's flare gun
and shoots Donovan meanwhile Cooper
reunites with Chase and the two start
reminiscing about their past together
the scene then flashes back to chase his
childhood it's revealed that her mother
Mrs Chase was a horrible woman who
always berated her for being weak in
hopes of pleasing her Chase secretly
joined kickboxing to make herself
stronger however Mrs Chase still put her
down for developing manly arms wait
until Mrs Chase plays The Last of Us too
fed up Chase finally takes a stand and
joins the Marines there she meets Cooper
and they develop a relationship
unfortunately during a mission Cooper is
injured while trying to save her and is
forced to retire from the Army the
injury leaves Cooper horribly scarred
but Chase assures him that they will
earn their living on her mother's Ranch
in the next scene Moses and Casey also
show up at the abandoned hotel and
demands to know more answers from Chase
this infuriates Cooper as he has had
enough of everyone treating her terribly
In the Heat of the Moment he pulls out
Chase's revolver and points it at KC
suddenly he gets a vision where he sees
himself trying to convince Mrs Chase to
let let them use her Ranch however as
always the Arrogant woman berates her
daughter from marrying a man like Cooper
one thing leads to another and the two
get into an argument in an effort to
Ward him off Mrs Chase pulls out a gun
but Cooper tussles with her and
accidentally gets her shot back in the
simulation when Cooper snaps out of his
vision he realizes that he has just shot
Moses in utter disbelief he then admits
to chase that it was him who shot her
mother this means that Cooper is not a
saint after all first he killed someone
then he framed Chase along with himself
hoping to get away with a lighter
sentence right then Bonnie and Clyde
show up and decide to punish him for
killing Moses but Chase takes his side
and a long battle ensues in the process
Bonnie is killed while Chase is impaled
through the stomach by Clyde however
before he could attack the others he is
pulled out of the simulation along with
Bonnie's body Chase is also pulled out
before she bleeds to death later she
wakes up in the medical room where the
board member Dr whis tells her that
she's been exonerated of all of her
crimes because of Cooper's confession it
turns out the surveillance team noticed
the Rogue Marshals just in time and
pulled them out Chase is relieved and
she explains that Warden Wells is behind
all of this Dr Weiss admits that she is
aware of this but says that they need
hard evidence to nail him Chase then
goes through a series of tests and
interviews from which she learns that
all the inmates inside the island were
actually on death row they voluntarily
decided to go to the island because it
was the only way they could possibly get
a shot at Redemption meanwhile the
corrupt Wells senses his impending doom
so he arranges a meeting with Chase he
reveals that her late mother hasn't left
a penny for her so when she walks out of
the prison she has nothing to her name
Wells then offers to help her if she
doesn't accuse him of anything in front
of the jury he also warns her that if
she tries to cross him he will make her
life hell knowing the chase is a woman
of principle who else tells her that he
tried to sabotage the program because
everyone inside the island are terrible
human beings and they deserve the death
row Chase agrees to help but she puts
forth a condition Cooper also needs to
be released so that she can deal with
him herself surprisingly Wells agrees
and Chase is presented before the jury
during the trial a jury member reveals
that 39 is the number of steps from the
end of the cell block to the electric
chair this appalls Chase and she calls
the whole experiment sadistic as the
conversation starts getting intense
Wells begins to panic and immediately
announces a 30-minute break realizing
that she won't keep up her end of the
deal he Corners Chase in the medical
room and proceeds to poison her
fortunately Dr whis arrives in the neck
of time and catches him red-handed after
being apprehended Wells is presented
before the jury for an interview this
time he finally admits to manipulating
the simulation including placing a
cannibal on the island he then lashes
out at the jury and warns Chase about
the truth later Dr whis injects
something into Chase and asks her to
look into the mirror lo and behold she
looks 25 years older and that is the
real Chase here we get to know that it
has been 25 years since she was
incarcerated and sent to the island her
Young younger self was just an avatar
they used to confuse her hearing
everything Chase feels wronged and
demands Justice however Dr whis consoles
her and escorts her out of the prison
outside Chase notices palm trees which
puzzles her as they are in Houston which
never had beaches Dr whis explains that
as the politicians tried to deny climate
change sea level continued to rise and
now Houston is surrounded by water as
the sea started claiming more and more
land people lost their jobs and their
homes ultimately they turned to crime in
the rehabilitation program was born here
prisoners are given a chance to find
their way back to society in the final
scene Chase leaves the facility and
walks towards the dilapidated Houston
while Casey and Cooper Welcome Warden
Wells to Island subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching